bonsoir nous sommes jeudi 3 décembre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour votre actualité locale
accompagnés de nos invités mais aussi
des journalistes de la rédaction on
commence tout de suite avec les titres
de cette édition
dans le cadre de la journée
internationale des personnes handicapées
nous verrons les actions menées au
château de versailles et nous
reviendrons sur les annonces du
président du conseil départemental
pierre bédier sur le sujet un nouveau
directeur pour le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines plus que jaro
est l'invité de cette édition
il nous dira comment ils entendent
développer les sites qui peine toujours
à organiser de grands rendez vous
culturels
et puis on sport notre chronique du
jeudi consacrée aujourd'hui au rugby le
club de chevreuse affrontera ce dimanche
le point avec un des entraîneurs de
chevreuse stéphane douchez et à
l'occasion de la journée internationale
des personnes en situation de handicap
le président du conseil départemental
pierre bédier a visité ce matin le foyer
d'accueil médicalisé de limay
malgré les 80 trois établissements
présents sur le territoire 165 adultes
handicapés des yvelines sont accueillis
au sein d'établissements belge pour
répondre à ce manque de place le
département propose la création d'un
foyer d'accueil médicalisé inter
départementale le point avec williams
elle sephora namani et jérémy quesada
lutter contre l'exil du handicap c'est
l'objectif annoncé par pierre bédier
président du conseil départemental dans
les yvelines et 83 établissements pour
personnes en situation de handicap
accueille cinq mille personnes un nombre
pourtant pas assez conséquent comparé à
la demande
165 yvelinois sont à l'exil
il ya de l'exil volontaire et
involontaire nous avons choisi avec nos
amis des départements voisins hauts de
seine et val d'oise de regrouper nos
forces pour construire un établissement
pour pouvoir accueillir effectivement
ces exilés s'il souhaite revenir en
france
en visite ce matin au foyer d'accueil
médicalisé de limay pierre bédier à
échanger avec les acteurs du monde du
handicap sur ce manque de place
obligeant ces personnes à se rendre en
belgique
pour la directrice de l'établissement le
problème viendrait de la non
planification des pouvoirs publics et du
nom recensement des personnes en
situation de handicap
concernant les personnes handicapées
nous recevons régulièrement des dossiers
de demandes d'admission qui nous
parviennent de familles qui
souhaiteraient avoir leurs proches à
proximité de leur domicile
et malheureusement du fait que nous ne
sommes déjà complets nous ne pouvons pas
donner de suite favorable à ces demandes
là pour assurer un meilleur
accompagnement des personnes en
situation de handicap psychique
un appel à projets a été lancé par le
département et l' agence régionale de la
santé d'île de france pour la création
de trois plateformes de service étalée
sur trois départements et pour lutter
contre l'exil du handicap le conseil
départemental 1,6 sur le projet de créer
un foyer d'accueil médicalisé
interdépartemental afin d'augmenter la
capacité d'accueil en établissement est
à noter que début 2016 à follainville
dennemont la première résidence
d'accueil des yvelines composé de 30
logements permettra d'accueillir des
personnes handicapées atteintes de
troubles psychiques suffisamment
autonome pour vivre en logements
privatifs et toujours dans le cadre de
la journée du handicap le château de
versailles a organisé une semaine
complète est dédié aux personnes en
situation de handicap
depuis le 24 novembre des visites et
activités spécifiques ont été proposé
une programmation spéciale est adapté en
fonction du type de handicap comme cette
visite théâtralisée sensorielle destinée
aux malvoyants où le spectateur est
amené à redécouvrir la sphère du collet
de la reine en faisant appel à tous ses
sens un reportage signé william l
cette année là c'est la règle qui domine
les grands appartements
c'est là que nous allons évoluer parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous allez être les
auditeurs des auditrices spectateurs
spectatrice d'une visite spectacle mon
sujet et le colis de l'ariège
aujourd'hui nul besoin de lumière au
château de versailles
c'est une pièce théâtralisée sensoriel à
laquelle ces personnes malvoyantes sont
venus assister pour une version total la
visite commence par une partie
exposition c'est à dire que les gens
vont au départ toucher les costumes dans
un premier temps et ensuite comme ça ils
savent exactement ce qu'ils ont devant
eux
et puis c'est formidable parce que très
souvent on dit on a toujours envie de
touche on dit non non non vous ne
touchez pas où vous toucher avec les
yeux mais pas avec les mains voila et là
bas non là on peut vraiment toucher les
choses la pièce commence et tous les
sens du public sont en éveil
ici pas de convention sans sel ni décor
les comédiens se déplace au milieu des
spectateurs en les effleurant une autre
et de l'amour et non la raison se tue
pas une princesse je suis une bataille
on est dans une immersion totale et
identification complète avec avec
l'action c'est-à-dire l'action est
autour de nous on est presque témoins
huit témoins privilégiés au coeur d'une
action
une pièce qui s'articule autour de
quatre saynètes qui raconte l'histoire
du vol du collier de la reine
les trois comédiens jouent puis laisse
place entre chaque scène un conférencier
poser comme narrateur de l'histoire
je suis en support
dans le récit et dans la précision ou la
confirmation d'un certain nombre de
faits de dates de lieux qui aident à
nourrir
l'intrigué surtout sa compréhension pour
cette pièce le château de versailles a
même réalisé une copie conforme du
collier de la reine pour que le public
puisse profiter pleinement de tous les
éléments du spectacle
l'autre possibilité c'est de sentir par
exemple sentir ce que pourrait être le
parfum de marc antoine est ou alors
possibilité aussi dans un moment
particulier où une dégustation de café
le sentir une odeur de café
on a l'impression d'être dans l'action
quand on est en est on
c'est très important parce que là tous
les sens sont en exergue
donc c'est pas c'est vraiment très bien
dans le château ça nous donne une
dimension historique est vraiment
formidable et ma chienne a participé
elle était au coeur de l'action l'a bien
réagi aussi des contraintes de mise en
scène qui pousse à trouver de nouvelles
solutions mais ici pas besoin de soleil
au château pour que la troupe plonge les
auditeurs dans l'atmosphère de l'époque
autre sujet à présent mercredi soir
avait lieu la rentrée solennelle de la
faculté de droit et de sciences
politiques de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
cette tradition annuelle depuis 2003
récompense les meilleurs élèves de
chaque promotion cette année ils étaient
une trentaine de major à recevoir leur
prix pour l'occasion un invité de marque
s'est déplacé mireille delmas marty du
collège de france était la marraine de
cette rentrée solennelle
sandrine clavel doyen de la faculté de
droit et sciences politiques nous a
parlé de cette cérémonie écoutez la
c'est un moment où à la fois nous
recevons un invité un invité de renom
qui fait il ya un discours cette année
c'est le professeur mireille delmas
marty de l'institut du collège de france
qui va nous
parler du sujet le droit peut-il
humaniser la mondialisation beaucoup
nous ont écrit pour nous dire à quel
point il appréciait le fait d'être mis à
l'honneur et d'avoir le sentiment d'être
soutenus par leurs facultés
donc oui je crois qu'on peut dire que
c'est important et dans notre entretien
de ce soir nous recevons une jarre au
nouveau directeur général du vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
bonsoir à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors vous venez de
prendre vos fonctions à la tête du
vélodrome qui a été inaugurée donc en
janvier 2014
il fera donc bientôt ses deux ans il a
déjà accueilli les championnats de
france et les championnats du monde de
cyclisme sur piste
alors vous venez d'arriver sur un projet
complété car le vélo de route nationale
peine à trouver son public
oui c'est clair ces équipements et les
magnifiques en fait mais malheureusement
jusqu'à aujourd'hui on n'a pas réussi
on a pas réussi à développer comme il
fallait en fait l'attractivité
aujourd'hui on a lu d un bel événement
qui était le champion du monde mais on
n'a pas réussi à captiver avec la
capitaliser sur cet événement en fait et
aujourd'hui l'addition principal de
l'événement c'est qu'elle va du bâtiment
ses claques c'est le vélo il faut qu'on
puisse faire d être plus d'événements
avec la fédération de cyclisme qu'on
développe plus de critérium de six jours
éventuellement ce qui existait avant
dans le passé lié sa avec de
l'hospitalité faire venir des
partenaires et en plus de ça
l'équipement permet de faire aussi
d'autres choses
on a il ya quinze jours en fait on a
fait une semaine qu'on aime comme une
compétition de judo il faut développer
ses activités ou l'équipement est fait
pour être multifonctions vélodrome cette
destination principale mais c'est
également un espace si on peut faire du
judo du ping pong tennis
toutes ces choses là donc nous on va
faire essayer de revenir faire revenir
avec les fédérations dans cet espace
leur faire visiter leur montrer
l'attractivité le fait que c'est un bel
équipement on peut se garer facilement
il et on a une vue comment facilement
sur tous les objets à facile surtout sur
toute la scène centrale
et en plus de cela en fait il faut aussi
qu'on développe la partie culturelle
là c'est un vrai défi parce que jusqu'à
aujourd'hui en fait il ya eu un concert
qui
et demi je crois ce week-end on a le
commando le téléthon qui va venir avec
un premier concert avec un musicien qui
est censé des rhinos on essaye comment
voyez vous espérez que les gens vont
venir et voir ce bâtiment vivre
autrement
l'idée en fait c'est que le vélo est
vraiment important mais il faut pouvoir
le développer et faire en sorte que les
activités permanentes qu'on puisse
vraiment faire en sorte que ce soit pour
la région pour le département et pour la
communauté d'agglomération un vrai outil
pour n'utilise 100% en fait ce qui
compliquait en fait c'est la notoriété
en fait les gens même je pense que les
gens dans la région ne connaissent pas
ce bâtiment fait il est dans un lieu
magnifique en fait juste à côté de nos
commandes de la deûle aire de loisirs en
fête qui est juste à côté en fait donc
lieu vraiment c'est agréable
l'équipement est tout neuf il est
quasiment pas utilisé donc aujourd'hui
il faut vraiment leur lancée allez
expliquer aux fédérations on peut
l'utiliser pour autre chose que du vélo
développer qu'inversion % le vélo et
espérait accueillir des commandes et des
artistes dans ce bâtiment en fait les
artistes qui aiment le vélo ou pas
d'ailleurs
parce que justement on voit la mise à
part le vélo est appelée événement
sportif le vélodrome il peine quand même
attiré du monde
nous avons justement demandé à
quelques-uns des services moi c'est
qu'ils attendaient de cette structure au
regard des bas peut-être qu'il y ait de
grands champions qui gagne pour parler
de 50 heures une nouvelle qui va
s'étendre plus qu'à vélodrome
très franchement je ne sais pas moi je
n'y suis jamais allé je pense pas y
aller d'ailleurs tant que c'est du vélo
je ne m'intéresse pas donc je n'irai pas
maintenant si autre chose pourquoi pas
d'autres sports wii puisque je crois
qu'il ya la place au centre pour faire
d'autres supports le cyclisme mais aussi
d'autres événements qui sont accessoires
ça nous rattrape et publicité au oui je
pense en fait foi ya eu beaucoup
d'efforts ont été faits pour les
championnats du monde c'était vraiment
une vraie vitrine et on aurait dû
continuer à capitaliser sur ces sur
cette vitrine
aujourd'hui on espère pouvoir accueillir
d'autres grands championnats des
championnats d'europe et aussi de façon
récurrente de championnat de france il
ya d un peu compliqué à mettre en place
avec la fédération de tennis de
commandes de ces caisses qui doit aussi
elle faire profiter en fait déjà en
france dans toute la france donc ça peut
pas être tout le temps à saint quentin
en yvelines en fait mais c'est vrai qu'à
terme ce sont bien deux complices et
accueillir fréquemment tous les deux ans
ce type de choses et puis des événements
aussi en dehors de cela en fait les les
athlètes sont quand même disponible
aujourd'hui nous on fait des séminaires
pour les entreprises ont fait des
séances d'initiation la dame qui a dit
voudrais jamais venu en fait faut quand
même quel est ce avec la vienne ce qui
est des séances d'initiation on peut
avec avec commander des moniteurs dm des
professionnels peuvent venir vous
expliquer comment ça fonctionne et c'est
toujours intéressant qu'il n'ya pas que
le le commandent la piste centrale est
aussi à côté une aire de bmx qui
expliquait aussi important qui est
homologuée pour faire des compétitions
on a déjà les pieds des championnats de
france de bmx
il faut aussi développer cette activité
pour les jeunes c'est plutôt fun ça ça
permet de commencer à pas mal
d'activités à côté en parallèle mais ces
règlements on entend vélodrome
les gens pensent tout de suite à vélo
est ce que il ya vraiment les capacités
pour accueillir d'autres événements
sportifs communaux mais parfois c'est
pas l'installation les capteurs optimale
pour d'autres pas si si on peut
accueillir tout le monde enfin si on
peut accueillir après la mise en place
c'était un peu compliqué ça prendra
quelques jours de montage ne pourraient
plus arrêter ni son pointures du basket
du handball du tennis de table m de l'
escalade en fait on peut leur on peut de
monter des murs il ya pas de raison de
la lutte par exemple des sports de
combat et j'ai eu de la boxe qui est
venu en fait et on peut vraiment
accueillir tout le monde et après sur le
spectacle on peut accueillir soit des
petites scènes avec par des humoristes
on pourrait faire uniquement l'air
centrale avec 1500 personnes face aux
assises où 2000 personnes debout sur des
concerts un peu plus important et on
peut monter en fait à 4004 1500
personnes pour des concerts plus
important en fait donc on va essayer de
d'aller convaincre les producteurs
d'aller convaincre les fédérations que
cet outil important et en plus dans le
cadre des candidatures d'une 2024 en
fait il faut le faire connaître parce
que c'est vraiment
vous avez des projets par rapport à
d'autres championnats internationaux en
fait on travaille en partenariat avec la
fédération de cyclisme d'autres d'autres
comme d'autres championnats de france le
judo est venu pour des championnats
régionaux en fait mais on espère pouvoir
les accueillir sur des rangées sur les
championnats en fait nationaux et c'est
aussi important les choix qu'ils ont été
satisfaits de l'accueil moi j'étais pas
encore en poste mais je suis passé quand
même sur l'événement il paraissait
satisfait donc il faut les encourager et
puis des championnats de france juniors
les seniors
tout ceci un match de fed cup pourquoi
pas et on peut toujours dans mes rêves
quand même grand événement français dont
on peut aussi accueillir d'un match de
deux commandes de coupe davis on peut
toujours rêver en fait après à nous
d'aller découvrir que moi j'ai travaillé
en fait dans un grand établissement
était maintenant la korité l'aréna en
fait une ancienne barre merci et j'ai
été en contact avec ces personnes là en
fait donc je vais retourner les voir
pour essayer de leur expliquer on peut
faire d'autres événements après on aura
on aura un aspect concurrentiel en
essayant de les attirer en faisant des
prix plus intéressants pour tout savoir
coûte pas trop cher par contre nous si
l'important c'est qu'on est
je ne crois pas non plus d'argent que ce
soit chose de rentable pour tout le
monde en fait voilà c'est ça c'est
vraiment important c'est la population
locale qui vise elias et de ressources
sur des populations si on peut dire pour
faire tourner vers un problème je pense
aujourd'hui notre cible c'est vraiment
là le département la région tout au tout
en fait on va pas aller concurrencer les
salles de spectacle de paris elles sont
très nombreuses et les gens ne voudront
pas comment vous venir de paris pour
venir voir un spectacle à saint quentin
a manqué une exclusivité je le souhaite
ou c'est pas le cas par contre pour les
championnats du monde les gens vont
venir six échelons du monde de cyclisme
en europe on peut attirer la population
parisienne mais déjà dans le bassin de
population locale il a tout pas faire il
apprécie mais c'est celle ci et pour
éviter aux gens de prendre la voiture de
prendre des bouchons et d'aller sur
paris pouvoir leur offrir à côté de chez
eux une selle important pour des
concerts importants ou des événements
sportifs importants ils sont pas
habilités et surtout du vélo aussi et ce
week-end la gestion donc le protéger
comme ils sont serrés motive à faire un
concert c'est difficile de convaincre
des artistes de venir ici à saint
quentin en yvelines pour faire bon pour
faire écoutez moi j'étais pas dans le
dans le projet mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui et lui est venue parce
que c'était pour le téléthon donc
c'était une oeuvre caritative et ça
il a tout de suite dit oui je crois
qu'il est aussi fan de vélo en fait donc
les deux couples et ont permis de faire
qui viennent le concert aura lieu à 21h
samedi soit et j'avais tout le monde à
venir en fait voir ce concert ça sera la
première fois il ya dieu m'a conseillé
en fait de dj aujourd'hui certains
enfants avec un concert avec des
instruments dans une configuration faire
venir les artistes justement à les faire
s'éloigner un peu de paris il a sorti
son habitude de voyager en banlieue en
région parisienne en fait ils le font
ils vont être partir dans des petits
théâtres dans la propre leur procurer un
théâtre enfin il ya un espace beaucoup
plus grand en fait donc c'est vraiment
intéressant et ajustements par rapport
aux éléments de paris qui se passait
donc les attentes est ce qu'il ya des
meilleurs de la confort seulement de ce
que répètent ils vont être mises en
place
ça va être compliqué elle n'a pas ça
complique l'achat la tâche c'est un bon
que les coups ça c'est clair mais c'est
important pour protéger notre public
aujourd'hui et tout est en place on
adhérait rajouter des barrières on a des
contrôles on a des contrôles avec des
vérifier le métal sur les personnes des
fluides pas des fouilles visuels de sacs
et si besoin en fait des palpations pour
les gens au fait donc tout et respecte
la loi en fait mais on était en relation
avec la préfecture avec les autorités de
police locales
donc tout est en place et aujourd'hui
pour l'accueil du téléthon et dans une
semaine pour l'accueil du noël du
vélodrome
c'est clair que tout en place et les
gens peuvent être assurés venir d'eux
sans problème vous avez combien de temps
un peu pour rendre attractif vélodrome
3e
bah oui j'espère que d'ici deux ans on
puisse enfin avoir des choses des
événements récurrents des c'est ça qui
est important en fait c'est de pouvoir
satisfaire des fédérations de la fed a
serré la fédération de cyclisme la fédé
fédération sportive autres et les
artistes pour que ils prennent
l'habitude de dire voilà quand on va
faire un championnat de france un
championnat d'europe on vient par défaut
on peut venir ici parce qu'on sait que
c'est l'accueil sera intéressant et pour
les artistes quand ils vont établir une
tournée ou bien faire des répétitions ce
type de choses devaient mal à cette
salle là existe elle est plutôt agréable
et on ne peut venir assez facilement ici
en fait et en plus la population répond
et vient façon c'est aussi important
c'est que la population
découvre saulieu et envie de venir en
fait on peut se garer facilement des
possibilités et donc il ya aussi des
transports en commun en voilà une
dernière question auparavant de notre
cité est ce qu'il ya une pression parce
que c'est vrai que ça va d'autres on m'a
coûté de l'argent j'avais une pression
aujourd'hui a vraiment un oui à une
obligation de résultat ont dit on est
contraint de mettre le maximum de moyens
pour faire en sorte que c'est comment
c'est ce bâtiment vivait avec épices
procurer du plaisir à toutes les
personnes qui vont venir voir des des
compétitions sportives ou des spectacles
merci beaucoup jarod avoir répondu à
notre question et je le rappelle les
deux événements de cette fin d'année
donc c'est le téléthon au vélodrome avec
et des animations de vendredi jusqu'à ce
dimanche prochain mais aussi le 12 et 13
décembre
un week-end dédié à noël pour les
enfants et nous restons à présent dans
le sport mais nous quittons le vélodrome
pour parler de rugby chèque je lui dis
vous en avez l'habitude maintenant c'est
la chronique sport avec les mutuelles
elles me d'euros j'ai bien installé
michael je viens d'installer bonsoir
vous allez viens on sent floué si vous
êtes doit le rugby les percées balle en
main les mêlées acharnée les plaquages
en pleine course et bien j'en ai tenu
compte aujourd'hui dans ma chronique du
jour coup de projecteur sur la rencontre
de fédérale 3 seniors chevreuse
contrecoup ya un match programmé ce
dimanche à 15 heures au stade municipal
de la ville pour nous parler de cet
événement nous recevons sur ce plateau
le coach des trois-quarts des chevrotin
stéphane boucher bonsoir alors vous
affichez à l'heure actuelle un bilan de
quatre défaites deux victoires en six
matches disputés cette saison
est ce qu'on peut dire que la victoire
est impérative ce dimanche impérative
impératif pas forcément on n'a pas les
mêmes ambitions qu'un club comme ouille
ces deux villes différentes oui c'est un
effet une grande ville c'est un club qui
plus
et logiquement cno nous on n'est pas une
grande île en est une belle ville alors
on est aussi un bon club et ce qu'on
veut nous c'est en effet comme vous ai
dit la dernière fois on veut se
reconstruire
alors je préfère une guy roux je peux
vous dire qu'on veut pas gagner que 20
ont déjà depuis tous les dimanches on
veut gagner on va faire tout ce qu'il
faut pour gagner ce dimanche là et puis
bon bain puisque on va jouer contre eux
auj
oui ça ça risque de faire mal en effet
voilà on va faire ce qu'il est convoqué
comment allez-vous faire justement pour
pour gagner cette rencontre
alors pour gagner pour gagner ce match
là bas
en général il faut marquer plus de
points que l'adversaire donc on va faire
ce qu'il faut c'est à dire que on va
continuer à développer notre jeu
actuellement et donc on produit beaucoup
de jeu on a des qualités aussi bien
devant que derrière
sa demande a plus de liant sa demande à
ce qu'on concrétise nos actions et puis
qu'on est un peu plus la tête sur les
épaules de temps en temps qu'on gère
correctement nos temps forts et nos
temps faibles et met donc on invite en
effet tout le monde à venir dimanche
pour une rencontre intéressante donc
dans l'est dans le département une belle
ville un château à visiter donc parfait
sur papier bah oui quand on aura gagné
ce sera parfait et au niveau du
classement vous êtes à l'aise à l'heure
actuel avant dernier du championnat ils
sont quatrièmes est ce que vous êtes
outsider sur cette rencontre vraiment au
sérieux on va jouer le petit poucet avec
des formes en étant et les pauvres
petits poucets mais il faut pas oublier
qu'on a un match de moins
tous les clubs se tiennent à la on est
cinq six mois même sept clubs à se tenir
en pas beaucoup de points du tout ça
peut tourner très très vite et ce match
sera vous l'avez dit un derby haut
rhinois est ce qu'on prépare un petit
peu différemment ce derby vinoy au
niveau de la préparation du match alors
là celui ci non non parce que moi avec
où il n'y a pas un historique
particulier avec ouille
il ya d'autres clubs oui mais bon de
toute façon un match avec un club de la
région parisienne
en effet c'est toujours un petit peu
particulier mais bon en général ça donne
des négociations n'est pas forcément
plus importante sur ce type de match la
motivation est toujours très importante
dans notre équipe
toujours très importante et au niveau du
coût de vos objectifs cette saison ce
sera le maintien quoi qu'il arrive le
monde divisé a quand même un petit peu
plus haut nous pensons et on pense que
le maintien c'est pas un objectif en soi
pour nous on est persuadé avec tous les
matches qu'on a fait depuis demain à un
moment on sait que notre notre place en
fédérale 3 est obligatoire par contre on
sait qu'on peut faire bien mieux que ça
et évidemment on veut jouer la
qualification
pardon on va jouer la qualification est
en fait tout pour y arriver et ça
passera par une victoire contre luis ce
dimanche à prendre des points contre
vous y allez prendre
merci à vous d'être passé sur ce plateau
le match entre chevaux et où est
programmée ce dimanche à 15 heures au
stade municipal de chevreuse et vous
passez à présent un sport où les rebonds
sont moins quatre questionne qu'au rugby
je veux bien sûr parler de travail
reçoit ce samedi à 20 heures le club de
val de seine dans son gymnase paul
mallet pour le compte de la 8ème journée
de nationale 3 les hommes coachés par
mustapha el hafidi sont à l'heure
actuelle dans le bas du classement après
leur défaite du week-end dernier contre
juvisy 66 à 58 les ide ne sont et ne
seront donc pas favori contre les
deuxièmes du championnat mais ils
pourront compter sur leur pivot joey
casseus pour l'emporter
rendez vous samedi à 20 heures pour les
soutenir forum et on termine à cette
chronique par un défi un peu fou
programmé au vélodrome de 50 ans des
grenats oui florane à un pari fou le
pisteur de vélizy 78
jean michel richefort va relever le défi
de rouler pendant 24 heures sur la piste
du vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines pour le téléthon l'exploit
est programmée entre ce vendredi 4
décembre à 18 heures et ce samedi 5
décembre à 18 heures le sportif sera
accompagné de pistard professionnels et
amateurs qui vont se relayer sur la
piste pour l'aider à tenir la distance
au total le cycliste de vélizy devrait
réaliser environ 650 km pendant la durée
du défi à chaque tour de piste jean
michel richefort collectera 20 centimes
d'euros en faveur du téléthon merci à
michael vous allez accompagner à jean
michel richefort sur la piste du
vélodrome de 50 ans et même nom
malheureusement je vais le regarder
depuis les tribunes je vais laisser les
professionnels réalisé le tour de piste
eh bien merci à vous et à la semaine
prochaine on vous retrouve comme à
chaque jeudi pour la chronique mais pas
de 7,8 sport ce lundi il sera remplacé
par un 7 8 politique henri en raison des
élections régionales mais
téléspectateurs se rassurent on vous
retrouvera mardi à 10h30 à 18h30 voilà
on nous parlerons automobile et du jeune
prodige de cartes williams bertrand il
sera également question de floorball une
discipline venue de suède forum
merci michael et maintenant place au
portrait du jour il s'appelle gwendal il
a 10
quand il va se lancer dans un des
concours les plus reconnus le meilleur
apprenti de france il a déjà remporté
déjà deux épreuves et participera à la
finale nationale le lundi 7 décembre qui
verra s'affronter les dix meilleurs
jeunes de l'année en alternance au
restaurant la ferme deux voisins il est
épaulé dans sa préparation par son
maître d'apprentissage rom indique el
fani bourdillon la rencontrer pour nous
alors tu peux être couvertes hamelin
trois jours à puce rempile boeuf
saignante et en dessert babana une tatin
s'il vous plaît il est 12h30 et en
cuisine à la ferme de voisins tout le
monde s'active au milieu des chefs
renommés gwendal 17 ans est concentrée
en alternance ici depuis trois ans il
suit rigoureusement les instructions de
son maître d'apprentissage
alors comme ça on est hélas pas cotées
comme ça gentiment sans casser s'il vous
plaît iphone os nous quand on rencontre
les jeunes il vient toujours faire un
deux trois jours de stage dans
l'entreprise afin de voir si eux ça leur
plaît et si nous y colle au profit
également loin d'être anti qui était
passionné par ce qu'il faisait et qu'il
avait envie d'apprendre
si à l'envi derrière on peut faire de
belles choses ensemble
à 15 heures l'équipe parents pause avant
de revenir quelques heures plus tard
pour le service du soir
mais pour gwendal et son maître cuisiner
pas de répit ils préparent ensemble le
prestigieux concours du meilleur
apprenti de france
c'est un concours qui se divise en trois
parties il ya d'abord une partie sur la
qualification régionale c'est une finale
régionale qui mois pour moi était dans
l'île de france
ensuite il y avait la demi finale
nationale et le
j'en fus à la finale la grande finale se
jouera ce lundi 7 décembre où les dix
meilleurs apprentis de france
s'affronteront dans une épreuve de 4h30
pour faire face à cette très grande
confiance
il faut savoir garder la tête froide
aujourd'hui sont mises en finale dix
parmi les 24 meilleurs qui avaient été
sélectionnés sur toute la france donc
ils sont dix à pouvoir gagner la finale
il faut travailler c'est un concours
c'est une épreuve d'un jour quand même
ça peut arriver de brûler un produit de
louper une sauce de renverser quelque
chose c'est très dur un concours 1 ça
peut être des fois très très violent sur
la première c'était assez dur à gérer le
stress tout ça mais bon mais c'est
derrière moi donc ça m'a ça m'a aidé
points pour y avait une finale que
gwendal aborde aujourd'hui avec sérénité
ils visent déjà le titre très convoité
de meilleur ouvrier de france et c'est
la fin de cette édition merci de nous
avoir suivis demain vous avez rendez
vous avec wilfrid enrichi pour une
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal avec
l'essentiel de l'actualité de la semaine
quant à moi je vous retrouve lundi je
vous souhaite donc une bonne soirée et
un excellent week end
vous